the time being 9 30 i would like to call
this meeting of the long-range capital
planning and utilization committee to
order and the first
where there is a quorum present
um
first order of business
is approval of the minutes
from our march 28th meeting do i have a
motion
been moved by senator d'alessandro
seconded by representative edgar that
the uh minutes of
our last meeting be approved
any discussion saying none all those
favors signify by saying aye aye opposed
nay
the eyes have it
i abstain i think i wasn't looks like i
wasn't here
abstain as well
it still passes
thank you
um
old business
lrcp
22-009 department of transportation
authorization dispose of two plus or
minus acre parcel of state owned land
located on the northeasterly corner of
new hampshire route 111 and new
hampshire route 28 in the town of
windham for by entering into a listing
agreement for a term of one year with
berkshire hathaway
vernet realty for the leasing price of
one hundred and twenty thousand
dollars allowing negotiations within the
committee's current policy guidelines
and pursuant to rsa
roman 3-a assess an administrative fee
of one thousand one hundred dollars
subject to the conditions as specified
up in the request dated march 8 2022.
this
uh was brought up at the last meeting
and we postponed final action on it
until today
was stable
so
thank you mr chairman um steve labonte
the administrator of the bureau of
right-of-way
new hampshire department of
transportation
this uh this item is moot what the
department has done is taken it off the
market and we're gonna uh retain it and
look for opportunities to use it for
mitigation credit on future projects
so we'd ask that the committee either
find it moot or
refuse it or
i've been
reminded i was remiss in one thing i
would accept the motion to remove this
from the table
uh second atmosphere they moved and
seconded that we were by representative
mills and representative claudia that
removed from the table
and we've heard the
the department talk about that we will
have a vote all those in favor taking it
off the table say thing why by saying
aye aye aye
all those opposed
the eyes have it and it's off the table
and we've heard from the department do
we need a vote senator dallas thank you
mr chamber i i think what uh mr lavoie
said makes a lot of sense yeah you kept
lowering the price and nobody wants it
why why should we we shouldn't give it
away we paid dearly for this property i
i bet to the best of my knowledge we
paid a fortune for this land
and it's worth it for mitigation
purposes it's worth retaining so i think
it's a good idea
yeah i i support your privilege
i take it from the postulate version and
make it axiomatic
thank you senator d'alessandro um and
that was the the essence of our
discussion at the last meeting was we
keep lowering the price and we're going
to end up
um giving it away yeah giving it away
all right
do i don't think we need
if it's been withdrawn
is that that's
it okay
then we will i'm sure hear about this at
some future meeting from a future
legislator
legislative body
um
moving on to new business under rsa
439-c
disposal of highway or turnpike-funded
real estate lrcp
22-01 for department of transportation
authorized to sell
4.903 plus or minus acres of state-owned
land with improvements located on the
southerly side of new hampshire route 16
white mountain highway in the town of
madison directly to calvin j coleman and
sun incorporated for 396 thousand one
hundred dollars which includes a one
thousand one hundred dollar
administrative fee pursuant to rsa 440
roman 3-a subject to the conditions as
specified in the request dated april
25th
and i will
elicit the
information from the department
thank you mr chairman um as just stated
the uh subject property is 4.9 acres it
was appraised at 395 000
plus an 1100 administrative fee this
acquisition was done
under uh eminent domain it was condemned
upon and actually ended up in superior
court
and was part of a global settlement so
at that time the department acquired
5.04
acres improved with a commercial
building and we paid
558 000 for it the problem arises is
that the building was intended if the
bypass was built the building was going
to be raised in the bypass
if you could turn your app the
department acquired
a temporary construction easement that
would allow for the raising of the
building
um right now 28
of the building sits on the abutting
property
mr coleman's property
so selling it directly to him actually
benefits both the department and mr
coleman because otherwise we would have
had to
value the property as vacant land and
then
deduct the cost of raising the building
because it sits on the abutting property
also acquired in that acquisition
um was a 10 032 square foot drainage
easement a 37 000
uh and 71 square foot temporary slope
easement a 4
79 square foot temporary drive easement
a 9 58
square foot temporary construction
easement the department is retaining uh
50 feet of a 50 foot wide right of way
and as i just mentioned the department
both the department and and
grantee uh benefit from this sale is
upon the building
again i want to say
we overpaid for this as what happens
when you're doing eminent domain
what happens is we condemn on the
property based on our appraisal it goes
to the btla
they come up with their finding this one
then
got appealed to the superior court
i'm happy to take questions
senator d'alessandro thank you mr just
one when when when are we going to be
finished
with disposing of all of the property we
purchased for the conway bypass remember
i lived in conway
so i know a little bit about the conway
bypass
that never came to fruition but but
now how much did we pay back to the to
the feds 25 million or 30 billion wasn't
that
where uh the last figure i had heard
were on the hook for around 28 billion
and
we've got to get decent
prices for these properties
uh
i just i hope we're vigilant i i
recognize that we we tried this a long
long time ago and
obviously it was pretty it was a good
idea when you look at the traffic but
indeed it never came to fruition
so we have to do what we have to do but
i think the board uh this group ought to
be cognizant of the fact that we paid
dearly
for all of this property
and and
we're getting out of it we had to pay
the government back we had to pay the
debts back about 28 million
so we we we have to be cautious as we're
going forward and
look at these i think we are and for
those of us who are on
um transportation the senator or public
works and highways so we we've
continued to hear about conway and have
to repay
the federal government uh federal
highway for the money that we invested
in that
um
what's the pleasure of the committee on
item
fourteen the move approval
senator d'alessandro moves approval
uh representative clutier seconds the
motion is there any further discussion
see none all those in favor signify by
saying aye aye opposed nay
and the item is approved
item
lrcp
22-015 department of transportation
authorization to sell .09
plus or minus of an acre of state-owned
land located behind 530 eastman road in
the town of conway directly to david r
smith in the amount of 2 21 100
which includes one thousand one hundred
dollar
administrative fee pursuant to rsa 440
roman three dash a subject conditions as
specified in the request dated may 5th
and
the department is up
thank you mr chairman department's
asking to dispose of nine hundredths of
an acre on eastman road in conway at a
sale price of twenty thousand dollars
plus the eleven hundred dollar
administrative fee the property was
acquired in two thousand six
um total costs at that time were twenty
two thousand three hundred dollars
the land at that time was appraised at
twenty thousand dollars
the remaining twenty three hundred
dollars went to a 646
square foot construction easement plus
the cost to cure
uh landscaping items
i'm happy to take any questions at this
time
questions from the committee
just
i have one first time i've seen it at
any of our things what is cost secure
fencing
so when you're
acquiring property under the threat of
eminent domain for a federal project you
have to make the
property owner whole so is if we're
coming through say we have to move signs
or we're taking out landscaping there's
a value assigned to that
okay thank you
just curious uh what is the pleasure of
the committee on this item again it's
part of the conway bypass and trying to
recoup some of the money
uh senator bird so moves approval
executed uh senator del sandro seconds
the motion is there any further
discussion
on item
22-0-15
seeing that
all those in favor signify by saying i i
pose nay
the eyes have it
and
the motion is approved
lrcp
22-16 department of transportation
authorization dispose of 2.88 plus or
minus acres of state-owned
vacant land located at one cronin road
in the town of exeter exeter by entering
into a listing agreement for a term of
one year with nia norwood group for the
listing price of five hundred thousand
dollars and pursuant to rsa 440
roman three dash they assess a 1 100
administrative fee subject to the
committee's current policy guidelines
and conditions as specified in the
request dated may 6
and we'll listen to the department
thank you mr chairman as uh just stated
the subject property is 2.88 acres on
cronin road in the town of exeter it has
been determined to be surplus to the
department's needs the
uh parcel will be marketed at 500 000
plus
the 1100 administrative fee the property
was acquired in 1959 for 412 dollars
the sale will accept and reserve for the
benefit of the state a 400 square foot
drainage easement a 4 275 square foot
another 4 225
75 square foot drainage easement a 4 000
square foot slope easement the buyer
will be responsible to complete a survey
and register the plans
thank you questions from the committee
and the town obviously
has first right
correct as with all of these okay
um what is the pleasure of the committee
on this item
uh representative edgar moves approval
is there a second second senator
birdsville uh seconds the motion is
there any discussion on this item
see none all those in favor of approval
of item 16 signify by saying aye
opposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
approved
item lrcp
22-017 department of transportation
authorization 2-1 conduct a land swap at
no cost to either party with the town of
littleton new hampshire consisting of
1.4 plus or minus acres of state-owned
land located on the south side of
riverside drive for 1.9 plus or minus
acres of town-owned land located on st
johnsbury road owned by the town of
littleton and two to pursuant to rsa 440
roman 3-8 authorization to waive the
administrative fee
subjects to the conditions as specified
in the request dated may 13 2022
mr lebronte
thank you mr chairman
the state property is 1.4 acres on
riverside drive the state would like to
exchange this property with the town of
littleton for 1.9 acres
um
on
johnsbury
i'm sorry i couldn't hey johnsbury st
johnsbury road thank you
um
the subject property was
uh used for as a highway garage it was
acquired in 1941 for 500
it was used as a highway garage and cold
storage until those structures were
raised it's improved with a wood frame
cold storage structure basically a salt
shed and a steel framed sand spreader
storage rack
department
use of the parcel um
use the use of towns
the town's parcel the department will
use for um it's vacant it's vacant land
the town will use it
the state will use it for a de-watering
basin for storage of streetways from
a catch basins in that area the value of
the state parcel was appraised at 35 000
to 45 000
and the value of the town's parcel was
appraised at forty five thousand to
fifty five thousand uh again we'd ask
that the committee
waived the administrative fee as
which is in its power
any questions from members of the
committee
seeing none what is the pleasure of the
committee on item
move to approve senator burnsville moves
approval of lrcp
uh representative clutier seconds
any discussion
see none all those in favor of the
motion signify by saying aye aye
pose nay the eyes have it and the motion
is approved
before we move on to administrative
services
um i would say that anybody who is
watching this
or is in the audience
it seems like we're going fairly quickly
the members have had the packets with
all of the information for over a week
the lb legislative budget
assistant provides it to us well in
advance so that we can read the
information and get any questions
answered that we may have
i know it sounds like we're going fast
when we're trying to dispose of real
estate but it the truth is that we've
all done our due diligence and looked at
the packets and know what we are
getting ready to vote on so
thank you very much and i think you do
have one informational item you'll be
back for
moving on to
rsa 440 disposal of real estate
lrcp
22-013 department of administrative
services
authorization to retroactively enter
into a use of premises agreement with
the county of hillsborough 329 mass road
goffstown new hampshire releasing
9433 square feet of office space located
on the lower level and first floor of
the state-owned property located at
hillsborough county superior courthouse
north
number
300 chestnut street manchester new
hampshire from january 1st 2022 december
31st
2024 for an amount not to exceed
378 thousand 22 dollars and 70 cents for
the schedule of annual rent and subject
to the conditions as specified in the
request dated april 25th 2022
and
administrative services
good morning my name is sarah lineberry
and i'm the superintendent of the bureau
of court facilities for the state and
d.a.s
um so good morning mr chairman and
committee members
as you heard we are here today to seek
approval
for to enter into a retroactive use of
uh promise agreement
at the hillsborough county superior
court north facility
um and of course it is for the 9433
square feet of space at the courthouse
that includes
space for the county attorneys
sheriff's office
and victim witness space on the first
floor and lower level of the courthouse
and of course the
county benefits from the close adjacency
of daily courthouse business and the
bureau of court facilities
currently does not have need for the
space
and so we request your approval today
questions for the department
um
why retroactive why why weren't you in
here earlier
i wish i was in here earlier um it is
retroactive
we've had some staffing low staffing
levels in my office and the county has
as well
i am happy to report that we just
replaced our contract leasing
specialist
in bureau core facilities
and i know the county has been
struggling with the same situation so
between review and attorneys and
um
unfortunately that's why we're here
today effectively okay thank you
uh any questions
on
the item uh was pleasure of the
committee
senator d'alessandro moves approval
representative mill seconds
the motion
uh any discussion
scene none all those in favor signify by
saying aye aye opposed nay and the
motion is approved thank you very much
thank you i like the new fits
it really uh it turned out to be very
attractive
and it helps us it does it it preserves
we preserves us it does preserve us
thank you we will take up one
informational item
from the department of transportation
lrcp
22.018 department of transportation
informational item proposing the
issuance of a temporary use and occupant
agreement to the town of hudson to
authorize the construction of water and
sewer extensions with the department
anticipating returning for approval of
the permanent utility
easement in the fall of 2022
and that the informational item is dated
may 13 2022
we do not have to take a vote on this at
this point
we are neither going to deny it or
approve it
but the department didn't want to
explain what was coming
thank you mr chairman yes we want to be
transparent about what's going on here
uh this is a pretty large scale public
project to put water and sewer in a few
different districts in in the town of
hooksett
um it just
we would have loved to come here with
the easement for uh
for approval
at this meeting it's just that our where
our appraisal section is just backed up
and we can't get the appraisal through
in time in order to allow the project to
move forward what we're proposing to do
is um
is to enter into a use and occupancy
agreement which would allow the town to
go in and construct it
we're talking about a 30 foot wide
easement
over two parcels of land
of state-owned land on the westerly side
of i-93
in the in the
in the instance that either this
committee
or
the governor and council don't approve
the easement the town understands that
basically the water line will be there
by sufferance and if the state ever
needed that property for a project or
the town would then have to move the
lines
any questions of the department
speaking only for myself and i'm
not even speaking for the committee i
if it goes forward i don't see a problem
with with granting an easement in the
fall if you can get it done but remember
this body turns into pumpkins in early
december
because
the new legislature will be meeting
after on the first wednesday after the
first tuesday in december
so this body will go away so we come
back as princesses
some of us will submit mr chairman if i
may so that means we'll have a september
meeting and then a november meeting uh
we will get to that in a moment
thank you
any questions on this
but i
the only reason i say that is to
work hard at it so that you know the
town isn't just on sufferance for years
we'll do thank you
which is our final item for today which
comes to meetings
in the fall i do not intend to meet over
the summer i know some of us will be
campaigning
some of us will be vacationing
and the speaker said we're not meeting
any for anything unless it's an
emergency in july and august so
but if there is an emergency we can come
in if something needs to be done
i would propose
um looking at the election calendar
which is important um that we meet on
either monday september 19th or tuesday
september 20th and i believe senator
birdsale you work tuesdays
yeah
okay
yeah okay
um
would the committee prefer to meet on a
monday morning or
tuesday
f it's well after the primary and
recounts
monday is fine monday okay monday the
19th at 9 30 in the morning
yep and then november 10 let's set a
tentative one um i would propose we do
it the week after thanksgiving
um the be between
um the general election recounts and
everything else i would propose monday
the 29th
of november
unless somebody
oh calendar
i looked at the wrong year then
uh
the 28th then
9 30.
and that way the departments will know
what they have to prepare for because
let's just be honest
we we convene in december for
organization days
it will be january or february before
all the committees are established with
members
and
meeting to get scheduled around
everything else that goes on the first
couple months so the department's
probably ought to be warned
that after november it'll probably be
sometime in february at the earliest
that whoever is chairman of this
committee
would would meet
um so
thank you for
for that and with that any further
items to come before us at this point
see none
i
motion to adjourn
representative mills
and
seconded by
representative clutier moves that the
long-range uh capital planning uh
planning and utilization committee be
adjourned
all those favors signify by saying aye
opposed nay the eyes have it
thank you all for coming
and for those who are on the next
committee we meet at 10 15.
you